j'ai envie de te dire au début très mal
parce que très mal parce que d'un coup
il y a quand même beaucoup qui rentrent
c'est quand même assez c'est un
changement de vie alors ça change je le
regarde pas je l'utilise pas parce
qu'elle m'intéresse pas parce que j'en
ai pas besoin mais parce que c'est
beaucoup d'un coup parce que parce que
j'étais très heureux avant quoi à quoi
ça va me servir quoi j'attends quand
même quelques mois voire quasiment plus
plus d'un an pour me payer mon premier
truc il y avait cet angle et puis cet
argent limite caché chez moi la maison
les copain il voit le truc quoi parce
que j'avais les moyens de me payer ce
truc là quoi vous aviez cette peur que
ça change votre vie d'avoir beaucoup
d'argent ça me fasse vriller un petit
peu et que je fasse un petit peu
n'importe quoi et surtout en fait à ce
moment-là ben je suis en tournée je suis
tout le temps sur la route je suis pas à
la maison j'en ai pas besoin quoi ça me
sert à rien donc le plus important c'est
c'est de payer mon loyer et que mes
enfants puissent manger tout simplement
incroyable non parce que il a alors il
était dans 7 à 8 aussi ils ont pris
l'extrait de retirer là c'est pour faire
de la pub à Isabelle Morini Bosc on
embrasse donc ouais mais c'est vrai que
il a c'est incroyable parce que c'est il
a eu il a une vie incroyable est-ce que
vous êtes comme lui est-ce que Mathieu
tu t'es dit comme non
c'est vrai que l'argent malgré tout tu
perds vite la notion de l'argent quand
tu commences à en gagner tes amitiés
sont différentes tes amours sont
différents tu supportes moins de choses
tu donc je je non tu supportes plein de
choses en fait tu sais c'est le fameux
truc bon Casta n'est pas là quand tu
divises tu dévisses mais le fameux côté
que tu commences à de l'argent tu
profites des choses si tu en as pu c'est
pas grave tu reviendras comme tu étais
avant c'est pas vrai ça ça c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai que une fois que tu
habitais les business sur tourne pas
l'écho donc c'est vrai que je sois
plutôt beau ce qu'il dit effectivement
l'argent ça ça abîme tout et que au
début si tu n'es pas éduqué pour t'en
servir c'est probable de tous les
influenceurs et de tous les gens qui
font de la téléréalité je te promets que
c'est vrai le petit Benoît qui a gagné
la Star Ac Benoît Dubois que tu connais
tu resteras
non mais il avait des parents de famille
qui était pas imposable et tout ça et un
jour il a gagné de l'argent et un jour
il m'a dit regarde ce que j'ai reçu il
m'a montré d'impôts mais qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire il savait même pas qu'il
fallait payer les impôts quasiment il
n'avait pas l'argent il faut il faut
éduquer l'argent avec les gens avec
l'argent bien sûr qu'effectivement sinon
ça donne des drames
une mobylette tu peux plus revenir au
Solex
je suis une passoire moi donc j'ai tout
donné si tu veux à droite à gauche
c'est un truc de fou et c'est vrai que
Jean-Marie j'entendais toujours parler
de ça c'est Jean-Marie il est arrivé il
y avait genre des tables de 25 personnes
il a arrosé tout le monde amené tout le
monde en vacances tu payais pour tout le
monde par expérience c'est le meilleur
moyen de de sur ruiner
à ceux qui nous écoutent Jean-Marie je
te reconnais tellement là et je vous
jure que c'est vrai Jean-Marie c'est
tellement un amour et tout le monde me
disait Jean-Marie t'avais une fatigue
plein de monde autour de toi t'inviter
tout le monde et c'est ces gens-là ils
sont restés à côté toi ou tu les as plus
envie après non non bien sûr je revois
d'ailleurs tout le monde c'est quand
même assez
théâtre s'il faut je dis un problème de
moteur mais on change les moteurs et me
regardait comme ça il disait ce mec là
il achète pas un yacht dans les îles il
met son pognon théâtre oui joue tu vois
donc monsieur parce que j'ai été fait
comme ça c'est le moule qui est comme ça
et donc je me fais engueuler par mes
avocats qui me disent vous allez encore
vous faire plumer tout et je me fais
plumer c'est le syndrome de Stockholm
est-ce que tu as pété les plombs à un
moment on va quand tu as eu beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent les voitures les
machins et tout ça non il y a un moment
tout d'un coup je me suis aperçu que je
pouvais si je voulais m'acheter une
Lamborghini Diablo elle venait d'arriver
c'était mon rêve de gosse j'ai dit je
peux le faire arriver dans le magasin
dire je voudrais ça tu vois et j'y suis
allé je l'ai acheté m'a coûté le le
tiers de son prix en un an et demi à peu
près et en plus la lire c'est une
voiture italienne elle a décotée au
point que deux ans après la voiture
valait
à peine les deux tiers de la somme que à
laquelle je l'avais acheté moi deux ans
avant j'ai fait toutes les conneries
possibles et imaginables enlève ton
masque